let's get right to it one thing i like
to do on this show if there's been
something that's popped up
in like the last few minutes i like to
lead with it if it's sufficiently
significant this is something that
is brand new the buccaneers are aware of
it they're trying to look into it with
their people to figure
out if they will have any formal comment
the miami herald reports that on october
15
before antonio brown signed with the
buccaneers there was an incident of some
sort
at his gated community in hollywood
florida where he allegedly
busted a security camera and threw a
bicycle at a security guard
shack the homeowner's community
opted not to press charges reportedly in
part because there was fear that
employees would be retaliated against
potentially by brown
and even though there's no specific
charge resulting from that
incident peter the reality for antonio
brown is he's on felony probation
from the incident with the moving truck
driver from
january and it doesn't take
much to activate the probation officials
to look for reasons to revoke probation
because probation is literally your get
out of jail free card
and you had better comply with every
requirement and if you
fail to do so on a reduced standard of
proof not beyond a reasonable doubt but
just preponderance to the evidence
if you commit any other act of
wrongdoing that violates your probation
terms
you're going to jail so this thing
potentially is very significant
depending upon whether to what extent
the folks in broward county move forward
with not prosecution for the new
incident but a question of whether or
not there was a probation violation from
the thing back in january
you know my first reaction when you told
me about this mike
is uh was was very simple i said wow
tom brady on sunday completed more
passes to antonio brown
than to any other person on his team the
buck scored 46 points
and he has antonio brown
has sort of morphed into very quickly
a contributing member of an nfl playoff
team
so i think the first reaction of the
bucks is probably going to be
well let's let's let the let's let the
legal process take its course
and my gut feeling is the bucks will
probably say
well this happened before we signed him
so this we're lumping this into the
category of everything else
which is let's see what happens with the
you know as the
legal as he makes his way through the
legal process
now i don't know what they'll do you're
asking me my gut feeling
my gut feeling is that they're gonna
hope that it goes away
but we'll see if it does and
it'll be interesting to see whether or
not the tampa bay buccaneers asked the
same general catch-all question that i
know the patriots asked antonio brown
last year when they signed him is there
anything
we don't know about the patriots didn't
know
about the incident that culminated in
the civil lawsuit
alleging sexual assault and rape the
lawsuit happened after he signed
the alleged incident happened before and
there had been negotiations on a
potential settlement for
months and my understanding is brown and
his agent at the time drew rosenhaus
didn't disclose that information which
poisoned the relationship and greased
the skids for a termination
so if bruce arian sat across from
antonio brown and said all right
let's make sure we know everything that
you've done
that you shouldn't have done item a b c
d
e whatever is there anything else
and brown looked him in the eye and said
there's nothing else just
days after this thing that didn't result
in formal charges but could result in a
revocation of probation
that's the kind of thing to get bruce
aaron to go to say to go to tom brady
and say hey tell your housemate get the
hell out he's done he's gone
that's it we gave him zero chances
and uh he's violated our trust by
failing to tell us that there was one
more thing before we gave him a job
that's a really good question because
yeah the patriots did ask that
did jason light ask that did ownership
ask that did bruce arians ask that
that's one thing we don't know i think
the one other thing about this
is uh that is is going to be
interesting to see i think
one of the things when you look at cases
like
this mike you know you you wonder
okay first of all if
at the facility at the complex
where this allegedly happened okay
what is the real reason why uh charges
were not brought
and what is the real reason why this was
not pursued
i don't know the answer to it but those
are the questions i
want to have answered as well because
honestly it's an allegation we're not
positive it happened
judging by you know you can't you can
tell a book by its cover
judging by it i mean do any of us doubt
that it happened no
but there's a difference between
doubting whether something happened
and then finding out where something
actually did happen
a spokesperson for brown said monday and
this is according to the reporting in
the miami herald
she has been assisting brown for several
months to resolve certain minor disputes
with the housing authority it's not a
denial
and it's something that i think is going
to be an issue at least in the coming
days again the buccaneers tell me
they're aware of it
they're looking into it they don't yet
have a formal comment on it
but i really do think one of the key
questions is whether to what extent that
blanket question was posed to brown
what he said maybe he told them about it
maybe he said
i need you all to know about this it may
come up at some point in the future
and they said okay we just don't know
but i have a feeling one way or the
other
we are going to find out in the coming
days if not in
the coming hours because bruce aaron's
did not want this guy on his team he
eventually relented
and if there's any sense that antonio
brown
was less than truthful when aryan stuck
his neck out
for brown that becomes a very different
analysis moving forward and as you
pointed out tom brady used him yesterday
he had 39 snaps on offense yesterday at
39
the week before he was on the punt
return team this is a key member of the
team
already from a strategic standpoint with
an opening
in new orleans that we'll talk about in
a minute to catch them and pass them
you you stand on principle you may lose
on on the football field peter
yeah there's there's always that
question and mike you know
you've seen it you've reported on it
that
someone with great talent gets more
chances than someone with marginal
talent
that's going to be the big question now
in tampa and mike
look this this has been a very
interesting year
for antonio brown in the books because
obviously
tom brady would have loved to have seen
him sign there and been there the whole
year that didn't happen
and then when he did get signed it was
clear that you know as i've described it
he's got two strikes on him and he's got
mariano rivera on the mound
uh with a you know and he's and
you know he's got no other chances okay
so now we'll find out if that's
actually true if something really did
happen at this apartment complex
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports